you guys have been making fun of me in
the comments don't think I don't read
those saying I don't know how to play
game I don't know how to make minecraft
yeah I'm a veteran okay I was born
playing Minecraft I played Minecraft
before you were born
okay let's grab these alright I know
there's a new bunch of new features
why is everyone spinning this is not
Brett stop god you're pissing me off I
can use this claw thing to cut animals
which is what I want to do come here
kitty let me cut you kitty I swear to
god kitty let me cut you kitty
done I didn't hurt the cat I'm just
trying to cut him ha Jesus okay maybe I
shouldn't run around with a dynamite so
where's my house again I forgot that's a
turtle oh my god hey can I write please
let me write that don't go I love you
nobody minecraft Turtles him alright
alright I need to get back to my base
maybe I should steal some decoration
where's my house I forgot where my house
so the goal of this episode is to start
a farm and enter Minecraft and maybe
redecorate the house just a little bit a
lot of you were saying like my house I
don't know what 33 getting higher and
dude I'm rich as balls did my bet is
epic as well like this house is nice I
don't I don't get like why you guys
Haiti
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so I know a couple things
right I know a couple things I can use
this bucket and I can use this sugar
cane and wheat it's it the sugar I use I
don't really know maybe we can plant the
eggs no wait what all right my dudes so
we want to make one of these a hoe
all right let's make a hoe people have
space for older she's right so we're
gonna make a nice little form I think so
to make a farm you need the hoe and you
hit the top that does not work what the
hell listen I spent six hours watching
minecraft tutorials why is it not
working maybe anytime I need to plant
the whole what do I do with the whole
now I can plant the seed No huh okay
oh I right-click yeah you guys thought I
wasn't good at Minecraft okay all right
we gotta hurry up we gotta hurry up but
this but the seeds but the seeds beer oh
god did you hear that
plant plant god damn it is that all the
seeds I have how do I get seeds okay
it's night time let's have a sleepy time
I sleep with my wheat all right
a new day a new life to live now let's
look at my plate look how much they grow
dude holy cow yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right this is going really really good
why is he not growing oh I know I live
hack life hack okay so you can take bet
you kids didn't know this you can take
bone and make it into bone meat and then
you grab the bone meat and then you put
the bone meat over the over there
this is like a pro tip a lot of people
don't know how to do this you do that it
grows quicker
it's whatever so now we have more seed
which we can plant hoes okay this is
pretty epic dude we're make whoa
how does bones work dude dad dad okay
all right we have a pretty epic thing so
now what you can do I figured this out
all by myself why do I hear zombies in
my house
okay oh my god I figured out all by
myself how to make a fence gate god damn
I'm smart dude I don't make the planks
okay
so now we built we build a gate right
outside our house see I know how to play
Minecraft your kids you absolute
children okay okay oh okay it's not
perfect but it works
god damn it now what we can do is we can
start taking people hostages ah what is
that sound
hello why minecraft spook me all right
horse hey horse you want some of this
you want some of this wheat come here
come here
what the hell listen I got weed man take
it what that freak what a horse it's
like in Minecraft useless you're useless
you can he stop spinning come here okay
now will you come I fed him wheat might
come here I swear to God I will murder
you come here alright alright it's gotta
be like that sometimes it got to be like
that too bad i alright chicken then this
chicken like this hey chicken yeah yeah
yeah you like this oh yeah you like this
oh yeah come here chicken come on
chicken
eat it eat it he doesn't eat it
alright you live today there's no
animals I murdered them all yes yeah
yeah you like this yeah come on follow
me
my fellow nine-year-olds that's right
follow me you're gonna live safe with
Papa boots in Papa's house come on keep
following oh yeah hey great son of a
snake come here okay we're almost there
we're almost there buddies my friends
you're better friends than anyone I met
in this game alright
just uh god dammit god dammit you came
this way alright coming alright and then
you go come on come in Nick one at a
time you dummies come in please come in
come on it's getting dark okay okay
that's true that's true come on come on
squeeze in squeeze in next one for the
love of God get in please it's getting
dark oh now you don't want to go come
here go in I'm gonna murder one of you
come in thank you yes yes yes yes close
the gate
oh oh oh
thought I murdered him what happened to
you why are you naked
oh my god I can cut you how how you make
baby
this is crazy this is crazy oh god the
baby escape baby can you now stop
leaving baby come back baby baby there's
zombies baby I'm serious baby sheep
[Music]
alright well bye then see if I care
I don't want to kill a child alright
fine baby you can sleep with me tonight
I'm literally see vegans see what I did
Peter I saved the life today
I saved the goddamn life what do you do
Kyle they're annoying alright new day
let's sleep all right we got our lamp we
got our epic farm everything looks great
thank you very much let's go out on more
adventures okay it's adventure time come
on grab your friends
don't have any to play Minecraft with
this is so sad see there's sounds over
there and I want to explore where that's
coming from
because I don't want no zombie farm in
my house whoa it's a wide chest it's
even bigger all right gamers yeah it's
time it's definitely something here
something real spook is happening here
and I'm not afraid to explore it oh my
god oh my god oh my god there's so many
[Music]
double kill triple kill
epic gamer whoa look at this cave it's
so massive I got a diamond pickaxe so I
can just mine for it ever bro what it
keeps going down what okay guys this is
epic minecraft adventure oh you scared
me Betty sorry you have to die as a
prize Oh too tiny to tiny tiny
that's right you then we're going for
more diamonds I want to fold diamond
armor very mean my diamond minecraft up
pickaxe dammit now I keep finding
material but I don't need but I feel
like I have to farm it this is all right
let's explore there's too much oh Jesus
Jesus Christ let's scare my balls ooh
all right we're laughs god damn it
who said mine cried isn't terrifying
Here I am minding my own business
dude look how my diamond pick is barely
move dude
diamond pickaxe for life brah for life
we got to get more we got to get more be
careful don't think I need this much
higher but I just accidentally dig up in
my own house
god dammit alright I got a I got a
shiryu we need more of my diamonds god
dammit that's all I want
Oh what is down there hello
what is this nun Nico day whoa whoa whoa
not like this not like this don't shoot
don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot
oh he fell for the old don't shoot
string oh god they're everywhere
what is this place
my god it's so mysterious I found the
new hidden cave thing that's awesome
okay
I remember now you can make a shield in
Minecraft how to make shield in
Minecraft I'll have iron on me god damn
it I don't have iron on me I can make
some
my god I'm scared this music doesn't fit
at all does that mean there's been
people here before me there's I'm not
the first one okay we have iron I can
make a shield now I know how to make
shield I know in my head you just make a
Y and then you put the PP in the middle
shield mother free-cos all right and
then you put the shield all right we're
ready for some epic minecraft adventures
now all right let's find some goddamn
gold because what huh well this sounds
coming from whoa this is epic ah let's
shoot don't shoot I am oh they're
shooting each other
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude we haven't found diamond yet come
on this place is insane dude oh it's the
baby zombie freak off I don't want to
kill a child I will kill a child I will
kill a child I don't have time for
children don't waste my time this place
is insane dude there's another chest
there who built this place and why
ah
that's what I thought Wow haha so much
lava there's so much epicness love it
stop
alright let's build a bridge right my
diamonds and I don't know what any of
this is but I got some goddamn melon
seeds Oh you shift click and it just oh
my god that is so much easier Oh God
thank you everywhere ha ha what do you
know my song oh god no oh this bed oh
this bed oh this is bad I'm dying I'm
dying I'm dying I'm dying to eat oh my
god did you see that whoa what is this
ha oh this is bad
oh this is it froze oh god I'm making a
hole
no one hurts the whole man okay I'm in
my hole I don't want to lose my diamond
stuff dude look how much stuff I have I
can't die
they're Poisson huh no that's too many
full strength full strenght whole
stretch full strap pull straight pull
straight oh Jesus
okay ah liberals
I'm not leaving until we get the
diamonds that's why I came here
whoa look at the heavens epic Jesus oh
god yeah found you
[Music]
they dropped from the ceiling babe okay
that was an epic adventure but I dare no
more we have too much precious item we
have to return see remember okay we
weren't too bad I just got to figure out
where the hell I am
oh my god here we are
dude look at my crops dude how are my
sheeps doing okay
very nice all right now we can make
melon right can we did we're gonna make
melon
all right beetroot can I plant oh my god
dude this all right some would say that
my house is not the best looking house I
get it maybe I should redecorate it a
little bit just a little bit I don't
care if it's dark I'm gonna farm
minecraft all day all day son
all you want some Oh God alright so here
we'll do the beetroot
there we'll do the pumpkin melon oh my
god is my stuff still there okay they
are oh god damn it
it came out of nowhere dude oh thank god
what are you doing to the Sheep you all
right it's time to sleep don't be greedy
Felix oh what a day dude I'm making such
sick progress except that one time I
died all right dude look how much
they've grown dude all right time to
spice up the house just a little bit
just a little bit make it a little nicer
fine all right you guys want a cozy ass
house I'll deliver I'll deliver the
coach Diaz house you've ever coast
inside to rebuild we must first destroy
it pains me to do this does it put so
much effort into it
all right don't escape now god damn it
all right I'll deal with them later this
is not your house mr. sheep okay first
we must lay foundation of the house make
sure it's good what the hell is
happening over there what the hell is
that excuse me I'm building a new house
over here what are they doing
all right we're building a goddamn house
one two three okay that's nice dude this
house is gonna be so goddamn tight all
you Minecraft haters are gonna be so
sorry this is the video series that will
convert more people to Minecraft than
ever in history notch will come back
from his grave
just to thank me thank you exam for
saving minecraft not just for saving
minecraft but for saving humanity you
don't even know what plans I have for
this helps i'm cry abla
i need to make stairs lots and lots of
stairs it's taking a lot more time than
I thought to decorate the house and I
think I'm going crazy just a little bit
just a little bit okay it's getting
there it's gonna be a bit guys what the
hell is this voice our cactus growing
melon this you're in through my house
yeah oh my god you got it stop we got a
house spider everyone thank you
well there's my sheep that is stable
good work oh yeah that's cute ah not in
my house god damnit it was waiting for
me oh my god dude I've been building
this [ __ ] house
[Laughter]
I can't stall right I'm going to sleep
goodnight I haven't had time to put the
ceiling but we'll do that in the next
episode smash like subscribe gaming week
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]